[Musique]
et on commence ces informations
Gabrielle par la première ministre qui a
réuni cet après-midi les 500 mèes les
plus touché par les émeutes urbaines de
cet été elles avaient été déclenchées
par le décès de Naël la première
ministre ellisabeth bornne a échangé sur
différents sujets comme le soutien aux
familles la prévention de la délinquence
la justice des mineurs et la
responsabilité parentale tout ça en
présence des ministres Gérald d'harma in
Éric Dupon Moretti et Aurore berger
ainsi que des élus ivelinois parmi eux
l'adjoint au maire de trappe la verrière
et les maires de Mantel jolie et
Chantelou lesvges parmi les propositions
de la mère justement Catherine Arnou la
qualité urbaine la mobilité et la mise
en place d'emploi aidé à noter vous
l'avez dit Mathilde qu'élzabeth band
sera dans les ivelines demain matin pour
aborder la politique de la ville et
l'égalité des chances on poursuit ces
informations avec une inquiétude dans
les ivelines sur potable oui les maires
de la Communauté Urbaine grandpis
saéoise estiment que 80 millions d'euros
seront nécessaires pour prévenir les
risques de pénurie et développer les
réseaux de production et de distribution
d'ici 2030 le conseil communautaire a
déjà versé 17 millions d'euros au maire
d'aubergville cette enveloppe elle
provient du budget général donc pas de
hausse de facture pour les habitants
l'objectif répondre aux nouveaux risques
comme les tensions sur les réseaux
hydrauliques ou les micropollyants la
région yvelinoise et le territoire
franilien le plus touché par le manque
d'eau potable et hier soir c'était les
grands débuts du basketteur Victor
wenbanama en NBA oui j'ai voulu trop en
faire je n'ai pas besoin de mettre
autant d'énergie en défense voici les
mots de l'ivelinois Victor wembaniama
après sa prestation mitigée contre les
Dallas mevrix pour ces grands début en
NBA le prodige originaire du chîné
rocencour a connu connu une soirée dé 4
très vite handicapé par le nombre de
fautes le basketteur de 2 M23 a une
feuille de statistique de 15 points 5
rebonds deux passes deux interceptions
un contre en un peu plus de 20 minutes
de jeu prochain match c'est ce samedi 28
octobre contre les Huston Rockets et on
va prendre la direction de Bougival une
maison un peu particulière est à louer
oui celle de l'ancien attaquant du
pariss sa-germain Neymar depuis son
départ du PSG à l'été 2023 pour l'Arabie
Saoudite sa somptueuse demeure de
Bougival est inhabitée et est
aujourd'hui à à loué pardon Mathilde
pour la modudique somme de 20000 € par
mois il faudra en plus ajouter 40000 €
de dépôt de garantie alors si vous êtes
intéressé autour de la table la demeure
de 780 m² possède 9 chambres et 14
pièces sur C étages elle possède
également une piscine chauffée une cave
à 20 un espace home cinemma et une salle
de sport la star brésilienne Neymar y a
vécu pendant 6 ans oui 20000 € c'est une
certaine sommeand c'est pas don confirme
que jeis intéressé hein faut juste les
payer ouis il faut juste les payer on
termine par un point circulation est-ce
que ça va bien rouler ce weekend dans
les evvelines cabriel et bien il faudra
prendre son mal en patience hein du côté
des départs ce vendredi 27 octobre ce
sera rouge en région parisienne et
orange dans le reste de la France dans
le sens des retours bisonfuté voie vert
le samedi c'est un peu mieux ce sera
orange dans le sens des départs en
région parisienne et vert dans le sens
des retours dimanche tous les voyant
sont au vert et bien merci beaucoup
Gabrielle Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news